[Musique]
l'idée est très amusante après un
lexique intitulé Tintin au pays des mot
les éditions araps à qui l'on doit les
meilleurs dictionnaires d'anglais
viennent de publier un Tintin et les
secret de la gramère anglaise ceux d'une
langue dans laquelle il est relativement
facile de se faire comprendre mais qui
est très complexe à bien parler conçu
par un agrégé Marc Martinez l'ouvrage
est des plus réjouissant il reprend
certains des dessins et des situations
des album d'Erg les traduit en anglais
et les expliqueent c'est ainsi que les
moins doués d'entre nous devrai enfin
pouvoir pénétrer les subtilités de la
forme progressive de la traduction de
depuis ou de l'équivalente anglais
redoutable de notre NES pasa il y a fort
longtemps que Tintin a été traduit en
anglais puis en une bonne trentaine
d'autres langues mais il reste toujours
distrayant de constater que tonner de
Brest devient thundering typons et mil
sabor blistering barnacles le tout à
Marlin Spike mouinsard sous le regard de
cathbert calculus Trifon tournesol des
Thompson les Dupon et de snowy qui n'est
autre que notre ami
[Musique]
Milou